it's a fact that fact checkers are
checking facts it's also a fact that
these fact checkers have no idea what a
fact really is we will analyze the
history not nearly a fact checking
but effects themselves then the APA
deems masculinity harmful Starbucks
needs to install needle disposals in
their bathrooms and finally the mailbag
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
the left is now decayed so much that it
doesn't even understand what a fact is
we will get to that in a second but
first let me tell you one fact that is
totally incontrovertible rings mission
is to make neighborhoods safer and they
are succeeding at doing that today over
a million people use the amazing ring
video doorbell to help protect their
homes ring nose home security begins at
the front door but does it end there no
way does it end there that's why they're
extending that same level of security to
the rest of your home with the ring
floodlight cam just like rings amazing
doorbell the floodlight cam is a
motion-activated camera and floodlight
that connects right to your phone with
HD video and two-way audio that lets you
know the moment anyone steps onto your
property you my viewers may have
encountered this when you were trying to
burglarize someone's home and then the
light came on and you heard somebody
yelling at you to go away so you're
familiar with the technology it's a
really impressive stuff I love it
whether your home or away the ring
floodlight cam lets you keep an eye on
your home from anywhere this is the
ultimate in in home security in the old
days they had a neighborhood watch and
all kind of stats guy that's old timey
use the new stuff this is way better way
more effective very inexpensive right
now you can save up to $150 off a ring
of security kit when you go to ring calm
slash Knowles can or wles
ring calm slash Knowles kano wles ring
calm slash what is it Knowles there may
be nothing more Exim to me in our very
shallow modern political dialogue then
the phrase fact-checking fact-checking
is this phrase that has come about it's
it's exploded in the last five or 10
years it is used largely if not
exclusively by the left and I can't tell
if they're being obtuse or if they're
ignorant I guess it's not when it comes
to the left that's not mutually
exclusive but they actually don't know
what a fact is you saw the fact-checking
explode during president Trump's speech
the other night from the Oval Office
let's just look at why mean there where
everyone every left-wing outlet did a
fact check then you have to fact check
the fact checkers in fact fact backed by
fact let's just look at one of the fact
checkers John King on CNN and just to
just to exemplify how wrong even the
premise of fact-checking is did he get
it done
he created a sense of crisis and urgency
along the way he also created a lot of
business for the fact-check machines the
president says a wall will stop the
drugs the heroin the fentanyl the other
opioids most of the drugs his own
government says come in through legal
points of entry where there's commerce
where there's crossing a wall will not
block the legal points of entry the
president said again the New Mexico free
trade agreement will indirectly pay for
the wall it's not how it works
money created trade deficits trade
surplus doesn't go to the United States
Treasury for free spending on other
programs the president also said this is
powerful when he talks about these
heinous unacceptable reprehensible
crimes murders assaults committed by
people illegally in this country no
question they're heinous and
reprehensible but the statistics show
you that the crime rate among immigrants
is actually lower than the crime rate
among non immigrants so that's
cherry-picking and seizing and trying to
create an emotional response he also
talked about the economic impact they're
taking jobs from especially African
Americans and Latinos a lot of American
corporations would tell you right now
they can't find workers they're
desperate for workers in part because of
a strong economy this president should
be claiming credit for so boom boom you
see those fact checks now I know John
King was speaking in his real in his
news presenter voice and he was on
television so it sounds like what he's
saying should be true but it wasn't it
isn't true no fact that he mentioned in
that diatribe contradicts any of the
facts the president Trump mentioned in
his speech just to go through what John
King said he said that wall wouldn't
stop the drugs from coming into this
country we have this awful opioid crisis
it's so bad now that it'll in large part
because of drug overdoses you now have
the average life expectancy of Americans
decreasing for the first time in 50
years he says that a wall would not stop
the flow of drugs into America wouldn't
help reduce the flow of drugs this is
not true he cites the drug enforcement
agencies of the federal government
the Drug Enforcement Agency has also
said that subterranean tunnels are a
major route of illegal drugs into the
country President Trump's proposal for
the wall includes dig
that wall six feet down to cut off some
of those tunnels and to say nothing of
the fact that if you have this giant
border along the wall it's going to be
much easier to police where those
tunnels are cropping up where people are
showing up then if people are just
willy-nilly running across unplaced
border so that one just isn't true how
about he says boom fact-check
better trade agreements with Mexico are
not going to help Americans pay for the
wall because the federal government
doesn't get all of that money well yes
and no in actually when you've got a
more robust economy then you've got a
greater number of tax receipts going to
the government so tax receipts to the
government increases dramatically
because people are making more money
they're paying more taxes on all of that
money so in that sense the government
does get more taxes also how is Mexico
going to pay for the wall let's say that
American taxpayers do have to pay for
the wall let's say that these new trade
agreements do help the economy but they
don't really offset it with tax receipts
to the government well Americans have
greater wealth as a result of the robust
economy and better trade deals so money
is fungible right either the money is
coming from the federal government or
state government or it's coming out of
your own pocket but either way you are
getting more money then in a certain
sense Mexico is paying for the wall or
part of the wall
or whatever so his fact they're also not
true and then finally this idea that
illegal aliens don't commit a crime they
commit crime at a much lower rate than
native-born citizens this isn't true
this might be true in certain state
crimes or local crimes but we know that
illegal aliens are 2 and a half times as
likely as non illegal aliens as as legal
residents and citizens to to commit
federal crimes now you could say federal
crimes don't make up even a large
percentage of all crimes okay that's
fine how about on the economy on the
economy we know that illegal immigration
hurts low-skilled American workers
President Trump says this in particular
affects black Americans this in
particular affects some illegal
immigrants from Latin America that is
true that is undeniable illegal
immigration
is floods the country largely with
low-skilled immigrants who does this
hurt low-skilled Americans for instance
you have a this is these are just
estimates from various think tanks 7.4
million illegal alien workers competing
with the 43 million other low-skilled
workers in America call it about an even
50 million low-skilled workers in
America well of those low-skilled
workers
black workers account for 5.6 million
and black workers have the highest
unemployment rates of that whole 50
million dollar pie higher unemployment
rates than illegal aliens in the same
arena this simply makes sense the fact
that black Americans are more likely
than other demographics to be
low-skilled workers means that when you
flood the labor market with other
low-skilled workers they are going to be
disproportionately affected you can't
argue with that that's that's simple
economics so there's the fact check
there the facts the fact check and on
the fact check of the fact check what
does a fact check mean because I'm not
just taking issue with John King I'm not
just taking issue with fact checkers at
CNN and the Washington Post and all of
these other left-wing outlets I'm taking
issue the problem essentially is with
the idea of fact-checking itself on
yesterday's show we defended alternative
facts because the left has misconstrued
alternative facts to mean untruths or
the opposite of true things in reality
what Kelly and Conway very clearly said
when she was talking about alternative
facts is that the Left presents one
narrative and a small set of facts and
then alternative facts which are also
true will give greater context and put
the whole event into a different light
and it will likely contradict the
left-wing narrative where did this idea
of fact-checking in the public media
come about factcheck.org was founded
around 2003 Snopes Snopes a famous fact
checker it was actually founded a little
earlier in 1994 but it was originally
just to debunk urban legends it wasn't
primarily political at all it only
really got political around 2003
actually around the same time as
factcheck.org the Washington Post Korea
it's fact-checker it's public
fact-checker in 2007 so what's going on
this is all happening around the same
time it's not as though public
fact-checking has been around as long as
journalism has been around it's a
relatively new phenomenon
now fact-checking as an editorial job
has been around forever
when a reporter turns in a story it's
usually an editor's job or some editors
job to fact-check it say oh no you got
this number wrong you got this number
wrong when you write a book I don't know
about writing books but I know about
publishing books when you write a book
you hand it in to the publisher and then
they'll have fact-checkers go through
and make sure that everything is right
I'm not talking about that I'm talking
about this public fact-checking John
King going on CNN The Washington Post
publishing a fact-checking column it all
began around this time the mid-2000s
it's gotten much wider in recent years
the fundamental point here is that fact
checkers do not check facts but they
give leftist opinion and they call it
fact-checking most fact-checking that we
see from John King on CNN to the
Washington Post or whatever is actually
in a EDM usually from the leftist point
of view that is trying to pretend that
it's not presenting a political or
partisan point of view so it calls
itself objective and neutral and
fact-checking where does this come from
it's actually not just CNN's fault it's
not just even the left's fault it's it's
a problem of modernity it's a problem of
our modern culture our conception of a
fact what a fact is has become absurd so
you hear this dichotomy all the time
look you're entitled to your own opinion
but you're not entitled to your own
facts which is a meaningless statement
it doesn't mean anything
because an opinion is the the facts as
somebody sees them so when I give my
opinion I am stating the facts from my
point of view from my perception an
opinion is not the same as a preference
for instance salty life
just tears or my favorite drink I really
really like salty leftist tears I really
like salty leftist tears is my
preference I some people might not like
salty leftist tears they must be insane
if they don't because they're so tasty
and yummy but that's my preference now
if I were to say leftist tears are very
very salty and delicious that's a
statement of fact and it's my opinion
because that's when an opinion is what
does the word fact mean the word fact
FAC T means something done I guess that
would be one way to describe the
etymology of it it comes from the Latin
[ __ ] RA and the past tense of that would
be in in Latin it would be [ __ ] to him
in Italian it would be fought though in
Spanish it's hetro in French its fait
you see before or after the fact a fact
is discrete it's concrete it's something
done the reason that we are so confused
over what a fact is in our modern
society comes out of the Enlightenment
it comes out of David Hume in particular
who gave us something called the fact
value distinction the fact value
distinction is to say that you can't
derive and aught from an is so I can't
say this is a tumbler of salty delicious
leftist tears therefore I should drink
it that's what David Hume would say he's
obviously wrong if you see a tumbler of
salty delicious leftist tears you have
to drink and how could you resist you
wouldn't be human if you could resist it
that's where that idea comes from the
fact value distinction so what the left
one's to say with all of their
fact-checking is look I'm not saying you
should do this or you should do that or
this is what I like or don't like or
this is good or this is bad or this is
my opinion all I'm saying is this is
what it is and then conveniently for
these left-wing fact checkers when they
just call it like it is the world is
what it is it always defends their
narrative one one person who in modern
times has pushed back against this
concept is Alastair MacIntyre he wrote a
book that was going around the daily
wire I think all
of our shows we've talked about it
before he he pointed out that this idea
of the fact value distinction is fairly
new so and it's and it's obviously there
are counter examples to it
so for instance if the idea is you can't
derive something that you should do you
can't derive an aunt from an is what
what it would have about the sentence
quote he is a sea captain he ought to do
therefore whatever a sea captain ought
to do what in this kind of a silly
example but it's a real example it shows
that you can derive evaluative
conclusions from factual premises if I
say another McIntyre example if I say
this watch can't keep time
this watch is really really heavy I
would never say that about my movement
watch because my movement watch is one
of the greatest watch has ever made but
if I were to say that hypothetically
then you could conclude it's not a good
watch you can draw an evaluative
conclusion from a factual premise now to
bring this into real politics the
politics we're talking about today if I
observe a few facts drugs are pouring
over our southern border with Mexico 60
to 80 percent of women and girls who
cross that border illegally are raped
human beings are trafficked over that
border our political regime is being
compromised our Democratic Republic is
being compromised because illegal aliens
are being counted for population and
representation in the House of
Representatives a country what we have
laws on the books that say that you can
enter this country illegally I can draw
from those factual observations the
evaluative conclusion that perhaps we
should build a wall along that border I
can draw that conclusion for I'm telling
you the facts I'm stating the facts now
the Democrats will tell you therefore we
shouldn't build a wall they'll try to
draw a different evaluative conclusions
but it's it's from this mistaken idea of
a fact oh just to use the border example
let's let's look at a clear one the
Border Patrol chief under Barack Obama
who actually was replaced by President
Trump he was on Tucker Carlson
explaining the rationale for the border
George Stein is mark Morgan he's the
former head of the Border Patrol under
Barack Obama he was then replaced by the
Trump administration and we're glad to
talk to him again for the second time
this week mr. Morgan thanks a lot for
coming back when you hear the term
manufactured crisis from politicians and
their lackeys in the press what's your
response my response is that those
people that are saying that anybody that
says that Tucker is misinformed and
they're misleading their American people
so before I was even chief the Border
Patrol I served in the FBI for two
decades one of my Simon Says I led the
El Paso office from my office right on
the border I could see Juarez every
single day Tucker we worked the DEA and
all components of DHS and we worked
human trafficking cases we were drug
cases and we work during gang cases all
impacting the southern border and then
as chief every single day Tucker I was
briefed every single day about the men
and women who are risking their lives
every day and they're apprehending
murderers rapists pedophiles other
violent offenders and gang members
that's not manufactured that is real and
that's a fact
and it still happened today that is real
and that is a fact he is talking about
facts he's talking about how many people
were apprehending what people are coming
over that border what they're bringing
over that border those are facts a fact
is a thing that's been done that's a
fact now usually when we're talking
about fact checking and fact checkers
we're not arguing over facts I guess
sometimes we are sometimes left-wingers
just want to put their head in the sand
and close their ears and close their
eyes and say la la la la la so they'll
say no we don't have people coming over
the border illegally we're not
compromising our electoral system there
aren't drugs coming up maybe they say
that but I think that's the fringe I
think most left wingers will tell you
yes people are crossing the border but
they should cross the border yes there
are millions and millions of people
crossing the border but that's a good
thing yes we don't really have solid
borders right now as a nation but we
shouldn't have solid borders as a nation
they're not arguing over what the facts
are they're arguing over the meaning of
facts which makes perfect sense again
this is another one of these errors that
we are now grappling
within our modern politics that comes
out of the Enlightenment that comes out
of this the fact value distinction but
maybe it's possible it is entirely
possible I guess that the left just
doesn't understand this the left because
it has such shallow thinking when it
comes to philosophy and politics and
history maybe they don't quite get this
but if they don't and listen up guys I
hope you're watching we're arguing over
the meaning of facts we're arguing over
the meaning of things this is why
conservatives should always talk about
the culture this is we talked yesterday
about about the different reactions to
president Trump's oval office address
and we said the people who are usually
Trump critics maybe they were never
Trump they're they're the fiscal first
conservatives I would call them they
just want to talk about dollars and
cents they think the speech should have
been about how the border is not that
expensive and it's not that big a deal
and come on guys let's not worry about
it
and then the people who really liked the
speech such as myself or maybe the
people who wrote the speech or whoever
they're the they're the cultural
conservatives they're the ones who say
go for the gore go for the graphics go
for the the moral arguments go for the
the emotion go for the faces of the
victims of people of these awful crimes
that's the reason we have to make those
stands is because we're not arguing over
the facts nobody really is arguing over
whether the wall will cost X billion
dollars or X plus three billion dollars
nobody cares about that
that's bean-counting what we care about
is not the facts but what the facts
imply what they mean the meanings that
they carry so for instance if the sort
of fiscal first conservatives or the the
conciliatory conservatives want to say
look let's just talk about what we
forget about the things we're
disagreeing on forget about these
graphic gruesome grotesque images let's
just talk about what we can agree on
five billion dollars isn't that much
money when you talk about only what we
can agree on you have lost the argument
because the left has a much narrower
view of politics than we do if if we
come in and say okay we're going to
accept all of the left's premises and
we're gonna argue
them over the conclusions we've already
lost we can't accept those premises
that is a recipe for losing you know
facts have I guess there are physical
facts we're talking about physical facts
like thousand illegal aliens a day at
least crossing the border on average and
you can talk about metaphysical facts
the the metaphysical facts of laws the
metaphysical facts of the moral laws the
metaphysical facts that govern our
politics those are facts as well and
when you're talking about the meaning of
them what those what that implies it
might be less comfortable it might be
less clean-cut it you know you can't
really do it in a soundbite you can't do
it in a in a CNN Don King soundbite or
John King or whatever his name is it's
Don King the boxing guy with the crazy
hair yeah you could I would prefer if we
did it with Don King actually but that
if CNN if any of the executives are
watching that's my recommendation for
your hiring but you can't do it with
that you can't do that with a little
chart or a voxcom article that says boom
fact-checked because we're not talking
about things that happened or things
that didn't happen most of the time what
we're talking about is the meaning of
those things and when you talk about the
meaning of those things you need a more
sophisticated moral dialogue you need to
look past these shallow little premises
of our very highly modern putt and
rationalist politics and you need to
talk a little bit more deeply the the
border really brings this one up you
know when it comes to the border I think
a lot of people think well you know
nobody really wants all amnesty nobody
really wants open borders nobody really
wants these things yes I agree I agree
probably in reality the vast majority of
people don't want open borders and
people flooding our country public
opinion polls show that too but we've
we've got to then be able to talk in a
more nuanced way a more sophisticated
way you can't just talk about numbers
and dollars and cents and say boom
fact-checked that that isn't how an
advanced society works that isn't how
civilized society works an even clearer
example of this is abortion you see the
problem of the fact value distinction in
the in the abortion argument
you'll say hey maybe we shouldn't kill
all those unborn babies and then the
left will say an unborn baby is a fetus
and that's a fact that's just a
scientific fact it's a fetus
or it's an embryo or it's a blastula or
it's a zygote and you're using all these
made-up words that that various that
refer to various things and that people
who have categorized human life at
various stages have arbitrarily chosen
they will say those things but you're
not actually getting to the meaning of
the fact the fact is the human person
from the moment of conception through
the phase that they call zygote through
the phase that they call blastula or
whatever through the glioblastoma
child to adult the the question is the
human person and if you want to talk
about that person you have to get past
these petty little shallow
understandings of what a fact is and you
have to realize that that human person
whether you call it a zygote or whether
you call it a bratty teenager has a
certain meaning it has a certain import
that we have to deal with and you're not
going to deal with that with Don King or
John King or any King on CNN it's an
empty slogan I mean I guess that's
really what we have to remember here
fact-checking
is an empty slogan and one example of
this it just came out in the American
Psychological Association the APA has
decided that traditional masculinity as
opposed to that newfangled masculinity I
don't know what that is
I think that's femininity I think
there's that the new masculinity is
femininity but the traditional
masculinity which is masculinity that's
harmful this is what they say they say
quote the main thrust of subsequent
research is that traditional masculinity
marked by stoicism Competitiveness
dominance and aggression is on the whole
harmful masculinity
ideology whatever that is is defined by
the APA as a particular constellation of
standards that have held sway over large
of the population including anti
femininity achievement Ashu love the
appearance of weakness and adventure
risk and violence now just as a again a
point of language we've got to be really
clear about our language because when
we're not clear the left perverts
language and totally wins the culture
and totally wins politics if something
is true for virtually all of human
history across civilizations as the APA
is saying this definition of masculinity
is then by definition it's not an
ideology it's not a formalized
rationalized abridgement of some
tradition it's the tradition itself so
they're using that word incorrectly to
make it seem like this random arbitrary
thing that popped up masculinity is not
a random arbitrary thing
there were downsides to masculinity over
aggressiveness whatever there were there
are many upsides masculinity is pretty
beneficial I think to nations at war
if someone declares war on your nation I
think you would hope that you've got
masculine men in that nation if you're
being victimized by a criminal perhaps
you would hope that a masculine man will
come up and protect you perhaps you
would hope that you're masculine enough
yourself to defend yourself also people
dealing with the realities of life and
this is the one that we can all get
we're not all going to find ourselves in
a back alley getting jumped but we all
will deal with the realities of life and
the realities of life require a little
bit of grit a little bit of fortitude a
little bit you might say of masculinity
and this is an example of the road to
Hell being paved with good intentions
what is really harmful what's actually
harmful is sending out as we're seeing
now as a generational problem weak
little buttercups into the world and
then watching them crumble and we are
watching them crumble I'm not being
hyperbolic
rates of depression anxiety stress among
Millennials and younger or through the
roof teen suicide is up 70% prescription
depression drugs are way up this is
because you have a an entire generation
now I guess two generations that has
been told that weakness is a virtue and
that strength is a vice and so when they
go out and they meet the realities of
life which are very difficult
even if we had the wonderful most
well-behaved society people would get
sick and died unfair things would happen
and by the way we don't have the perfect
totally fair society so there going to
be more hardships than that it's no
benefit to anybody to tell people to be
weak and the APA in just talking about
the facts in just talking about the
science is is forming conclusions that
are absurd they are they are they are
writing left-wing op eds which I'm not
surprised I mean they are they are
conveying a leftist political narrative
and pretending that it is science it is
exactly the same thing that John King is
doing on CNN or the Washington Post is
doing or all of those other left-wing
news outlets unfortunately this is
affected not just psychology but much of
our academic establishment and it's not
true we have to point out to them that
those facts aren't facts it's their
interpretation of the facts it's their
narrative of the meaning of the facts
and what we need to do is present to
them something different you might say
we need to present to them
alternative facts and we need to present
to them an alternative interpretation of
the facts we've got a lot more to get to
but we don't have time so we're gonna
cut right to the mailbag but first but
first go over to Daly wire.com
why what do you get what don't you get
at this point you get me you get the
Andrew Clavin show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get the Matt Walsh show
you get to ask questions in the mailbag
coming up your test questions in
backstage you get to watch another
Kingdom you get you get everything you
get everything but most importantly you
get this the leftists here's tumblr and
let me tell you something there's no
alternative to the leftist tears tumblr
this is a fact you can derive an art
from this fact which is you ought to
drink those salty delicious leftist
tears otherwise you're going to drown
you don't want that to happen go over
there right now $9.99 a month $100 for
an annual membership you get all of that
and so much more go to daily wire com
we'll be right back with the mailbag
all right let's cut right to the mailbag
I had so many more stories to talk about
but it's look at the clock says what the
clock says that's just a fact okay we're
just talking about the facts first
question from Aslan Michael why do you
think that the write is superior in the
meme war is it our ability to take a
joke or is it the total failure on the
left to say that being politically
incorrect is a death sentence
I for one enjoy the memes all around
Thank You Aslan the reason why the right
is so much better at memes and the
internet the reason that the left can't
meme comes down to clarity of vision and
fortitude it actually comes down to what
we were just saying the reason memes
what what a meme is an internet meme is
an image that strut just strikes you as
usually funny and funny because it's
true it cuts to the heart of some point
in maybe no words or maybe a couple of
words or images or juxtapositions of
images and then it goes viral because so
many people think it's true and funny
the reason that the write broadly is
better at comedy right now is because of
clarity and vision and fortitude
I say clarity of vision because the left
can't meme because no one finds it to be
true no one finds their images to be
true but when you go see a comedy show
you you say it's funny because it's true
but if what they're saying isn't true if
they're using the language of political
correctness if they're using euphemisms
and soft words and lies you're it's just
not going to be true the language of PC
the language of the left is designed to
obscure the truth and so they can't do
that the other reason why they can't
meme is because they don't have
fortitude they don't have strength so
they're so concerned about offending
everybody this is ostensibly the premise
of political correctness that they can't
take a joke themselves and they're
unwilling to make a joke about anyone
else I am willing to make just about any
joke about anybody and I'm willing to
take just about any joke and it doesn't
really bother me why doesn't it bother
me I don't feel threatened by them I
don't
then come in a crumble I don't put all
of my stock in how other people perceive
me I don't think that my virtue is
measured by what left-wing people on
social media think about me I think my
virtue is measured by namely virtue so
those would be some of the reasons why
right-wingers have the grit and the
thick skin and the fortitude to take a
joke and if you can take a joke you can
tell a joke the left can't do that
either and so because they're blind and
because they're weak they can't mean
from Andrew dear mr. Knowles funniest
guy on The Daily wire I'm funny half
funny like I'm a clown like I am you
I'll go on I hear a lot of people talk
about how the Protestant Reformation and
Protestant ideas led to the formation of
the greatest country in the history of
the world the United States of America
as a Catholic I feel a little
disenfranchised should I be thoughts no
pants I think that's his name that he
signed it with no pants I see your point
I had four ancestors on the Mayflower
those Mayflower pilgrims were religious
zealots they were highly Protestant they
are probably rolling over in their
graves knowing that their descendant is
a pope ish papist such as I am it is
largely Protestant America in in much of
its thinking and much of its history I
think it was Arthur Schlessinger said
that anti Catholicism is the deepest
bias in American history however however
who discovered America Oh would it
happen to be that devoted Catholic
extremist Christopher Columbus who at a
time of widespread illiteracy made sure
to read the Bible constantly who prayed
the Catholic Book of Hours constantly on
his passage to America would it be that
guy of course it was founded by a
Catholic and not just that the country
is named after a Catholic
Amerigo Vespucci from from whom we get
America and not just named after that
Catholic cartographer but not just the
country but the whole continent is named
after him not just the whole continent
but the other continent in this
hemisphere to the whole damn new world
is named after a Catholic and it was
discovered by a Catholic that's pretty
good you can hang your hat on
and have a little pride even though the
Protestants came in much later and and
seemed to take over much of the
political development of the country
from Tyler hi Michael I have struggled
in the past with drug addiction
depression and continue to struggle I
have my good weeks in my bad weeks I
wanted to better myself and give myself
strength through these troubling times
with Christianity my family has always
been pretty religious but I've always
felt myself on the fence with religion
in general I have a very high respect
for the religious practice and admire
people who truly believe I was wondering
if you had some advice for a soul
struggling to find God and a meaning for
life thanks yes I do
first God exists God loves you
your life has incalculable meaning and
worth those three things are true that's
a fact
you can quibble with my facts but it is
a fact so know that even if you have
trouble understanding that or accepting
that that is true
speaking of truth CS Lewis put it very
well and this is probably the best
advice I can give you you say that
you're not that religious personally but
you admire religious people you want to
be religious you okay CS Lewis wrote if
you look for truth you may find comfort
in the end if you look for comfort you
will not find either truth or comfort
only soft soap and wishful thinking to
begin and in the end despair if you are
looking to be comforted by religion
because you've had a tough run of it and
you've you've struggled with various
ailments you will you will end up
despairing it will not work if you look
for the truth you'll get all of those
things if you follow the truth to its
logical conclusions you will you will
get those things and if you don't follow
it maybe you won't but you won't be any
worse off than you would be if you only
looked for comfort look for the truth
above all things that's the best advice
I can give you from Nicole I recently
had a Democratic mayor in Massachusetts
call me sexist because I told him I
would not want to be friends when I was
in a relationship this being because we
went on a couple dates and talked at all
hours of the night this would obviously
be disrespectful to a relationship he
said I was treating him differently
because he was a male and it was the
definition of sexism what do you think I
think that this person is upset that you
are not giving him the definition of sex
I don't think it has anything to do with
the definition of sexism when I first
when I read the first part of your
question can you be friends with a woman
if you're if you're married to a woman
or can you be free you know can you be
friends with members of the opposite sex
yeah of course you can unless they're
trying to date you if you've gone on
dates with this person you're calling
this person at 3 o'clock in the morning
probably not a great idea sounds like
this guy he's a Democrat politician
right sounds like he's trying to get in
your pants so I wouldn't take a line
like that you'd think he'd be able to
muster a better line than your sexist I
guess he's a Democrats the only thing
they can say you're racist you're sexist
you're bigoted don't buy it honey he's
trying to pull a fast one from Katherine
hey Michael big fan I recently graduated
from college and I'm having trouble
finding a full-time job once I turned 26
I lost my parents insurance and since
then they and my friends have been
encouraging me to sign up for Medicare
because I don't believe in Medicare that
seems a little hypocritical to me but
one of my friends argued that I would
only be using it as a safety net until I
find a full-time job and that this is
its true purpose thoughts thanks for the
response Kat okay a lot of things here
one you're 26 you graduated college we
have the most robust employment market
in recent history right now you should
be able to get a full-time job
there are right now more jobs hiring
than people who can fill those jobs you
went to college presumably you paid some
money to go to college you should be
able to get a job if you can't get a job
maybe it's because you don't live in a
place where you can get a job in that
case it might be worth moving to go get
a job might be worth commuting a little
further to go get a job it might be the
case that you don't have a full-time job
because while
you could get a job that you don't want
you can't quite get a job yet in the
career that you want to get a job in if
that is the case take the job be a
barista be a waiter buy I live in LA a
lot of my friends are actors everybody's
a waiter take a job that you can get now
having a job is better than not having a
job having a job that you don't want is
better than not having a job that you do
want do that okay that's my advice for
getting a job because you should be able
to get a job in this market with a
college education age 26 you should be
able to do it and if you can't then
there's something wrong either
geographically or philosophically and
you should tweak that that said I I
don't think you're talking about
Medicare which is the entitlement
program for old people for senior
citizens I think you're talking about
Medicaid which is for people who are
down on their luck or out of work or
aren't making very much money there's
nothing wrong with being opposed to the
expansion of the welfare state and then
using those programs when you need to
use them there's nothing wrong about
that whatsoever it's not that you don't
believe in the welfare programs you
certainly believe in them when you have
a job you'll pay into them I believe in
them they exist they're the biggest
driver of our debt and deficit there is
nothing wrong with that
especially in the short term if you're
just down on your luck and you haven't
been able to pick yourself back up yet
there is nothing wrong about using those
programs and also it's it's ridiculous
for the left to ask us to unilaterally
disarm so we have to pay for all these
programs we have to support the
expansion of this entitlement state but
then because we think that it would be
better to shrink that entitlement state
we're not allowed to use those programs
that's a ridiculous unilateral
disarmament that we should never do
don't feel bad about that don't feel bad
about taking a hand up when you need one
but also make sure that you can get up I
mean make sure that you don't allow that
to trap you into a complacency that will
really not serve your life and take
advantage of a very strong employment
market right now to go get a job might
not be the job you want but it'll help
you get the job that you want from Evan
to the four-star general of Christmas
Michael Knowles what document should
public officials swear
on when they take the oath of office I
understand why taking the oath on your
religious text is good but shouldn't the
most important document to Americans be
the Constitution and that be the
standard-bearer for such an oath Evan no
they should take the oath of office on a
Bible or I suppose if they're not
Christian or Jewish on whatever other
religious text they want to take it on
the most important document to me is not
the Constitution
I love the Constitution big defender of
the Constitution it's right up there
maybe it's number two I don't know but
it's not the most important because the
this physical world this life that we're
in right now is not the most important
thing to me there are greater things
than just the here and now there is
eternal life there are moral questions
there is a moral law there is my Creator
who created me a contingent being that
is why you have to take the oath on the
Bible or whatever religious texts you
want to take it on it what the reason
why we did that in the first place with
the exception I think of the Adams is
John and John Quincy Adams the
presidents have all done it have all
taken the oath on the Bible and it's
because if you take the oath on the
Constitution and then you violate the
Constitution what happens to you not too
much if you take the oath on the Bible
and you believe in that religion you're
a Christian you believe in an eternal
judge you believe in judgment and sin
and grace and the moral law and you
violate that there are consequences for
you even if you're the most important
politician in the world even if you're
the president of the United States there
will be consequences because there is a
more powerful judge in heaven to whom
you will have to answer that's why you
take the oath on a religious text now
taking the oath on a religious text if
you don't actually believe all that is
meaningless you might as well take it on
the menu at McDonald's but if that's
also a reason why our politics suffers
when we have a weak culture that derives
from a country that has lost its
religious understanding & Moring and
direction from Kevin hi Michael should
men always offer to pay for dates I was
raised in a traditional conservative
family and
grew up thinking that gentlemen offered
to pay for their dates meals I just
graduated from college last year and I
was shocked by my experience with guys
who were otherwise polite feeling
comfortable to go dutch additionally
many girls that I know don't expect men
to offer to pay what do you think love
the show
men should pay for dates yes especially
after college I guess in college
everyone's poor and it's a little
tougher especially after college men
should pay for dates they should at
least pay for the first date and what
they should always do is offer to pay so
you point out I actually I think a
couple words were cut out there that
that men suggest going Dutch men should
never suggest going Dutch never do it
that's a very bad idea I don't care if
she comes from the Vanderbilt family and
you you know are living on the street or
something never suggest going Dutch with
a woman on a date now because of the
fact of our modern world modern dating
where you can modern swype culture where
you could be going on a zillion dates a
week and there's not a lot of commitment
and our economy is such that most women
are working and all of that I'm not
opposed to - maybe in your 20s splitting
a cheque or agreeing to split a check
but you should never suggest it you the
man should always offer to pay these are
just the chivalrous polite mores that
make society better that make it nicer
that make a date not just some clinical
transaction where you're gonna split a
bill and sign a contract and you know go
back home and do whatever but you've got
to make it all clinical this is this is
about romantic engagement this is about
seduction this is about saying I am
giving something to you I've invited you
here I want to do something for you I'm
demonstrating that I'm pleased that
you're here and that I'm enjoying this
and that's why you should the man should
always offer to pay if the woman insists
on it that's a very nice thing too
because she's she's saying I'm I so
appreciate being here
I don't want you to think I'm taking
advantage of you that you pay for every
date let me pay for one out of ten dates
or whatever there's a nice dance there
there's a nice transaction a moral
transaction a romantic transaction
that's going on and not just a clinical
transaction which you see so much in
modern day
I'm taking one more I don't even care
from Alexander would it be idolatry to
pray for America similar to how Old
Testament Jews prayed for Israel America
isn't directly a promised land you sure
about that so would praying for the
success and prosperity of our country be
asking the wrong thing of God no it's a
perfectly wonderful thing to ask God to
pray for our country and we should do it
all the time god bless america
now if you were praying to your country
that would be idolatry if you were
worshiping your country that would be
idolatry and some people do that we make
idols out of all sorts of things all of
us do it but with that we should resist
but if you're praying to God to bless
your country your country is your home
it's an extension in many ways of
yourself you you are you you're your
person and you have your family you
could ask God to pray for your family I
don't think that's idolatry of the
family you could ask God to pray for
your friends in your community
that's not idolatry of the community and
taken to the broadest level in the world
order right now that's asking God to
pray for your nation which is your your
big community that's a wonderful thing
we should ask God to do it all the time
and it will also far from being idolatry
it will actually counter idolatry by
making it clear that our nation
wonderful as it is is beneath God it is
below God and it is in so many ways a
fact of the Providence of God all right
that's our show I had more to get to but
too bad I hope you have a good weekend
I'm gonna now head to the studio and
record the audiobook of another Kingdom
which is coming out so if you haven't
binge to the podcasts go do it then
you'll be ready for the audio book in
the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Nolt show I'll see you on
Monday
[Music]
show is produced by Robert Stirling
executive producer Jeremy Moore senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis clever and our
technical producer is Austin Stephens
edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is mixed by
Dylan case production assistant Nick
Shyam hair and makeup is by Jesuit Vera
the Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19